je vous enlève sa voix là et merci
beaucoup merci notre politique ce matin
nous sommes ravis de vous accueillir
ancien ministre des affaires étrangères
président de l'institut françois
mitterrand dit ensemble pendant un petit
peu plus de vingt minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et de ouest-france violence mes fans
bonjour bonjour
et bienvenue green on va commencer avec
ce discours hier discours d' emmanuel
macron à strasbourg discours sur
l'europe il a relancé une idée de
françois mitterrand il veut créer une
communauté politique européenne un
nouvel espace pour les pays européens
qui partagent nos valeurs mais ne sont
pas dans l'union européenne vous saluer
cette idée du chef de l'état
moi je me réjouis qu'on relance une idée
non seulement parce qu'à l'origine c'est
françois mitterrand guidées proposées
mais trop tôt c'était mal préparé et à
l'époque il voulait inclure la russie
dans le schéma d'une façon assez
gaullienne mais en fait elle c'est
l'époque de gorbatchev et mitterrand
comme pour les doudous les grands
matches bref et l'idée d'une
confédération en partant de l'idée que
les pays d'europe avaient vocation à
entrer dans l'union mais que la
négociation sur les longues difficiles
énervante c'est vrai que je sens en
attendant allez pas les mettre dans ce
main packing linois de garage mais sans
attendre il fallait avoir une une
instance 1-1 cas dans lequel se serait
il une relation d'égalité ça n'a pas
marché du tout pour des tas de raisons
parce que les mails il ya un malentendu
sur la question ruches sur la
chronologie sa guide avait disparu mais
c'est une des plus grandes idées qui est
humide iront d'ailleurs sur l'échangé
complètement comme le dit enrico letta
l'ancien président du conseil italien
qui a relancé l'idée ces dernières
semaines été repris sous une forme un
peu différente par le prison macron sur
les complètement changé les relations
entre l'europe de l'est et de l'ouest
dans les dernières décennies enfin bon
ça n'ait pas marché
on n'en sait rien puisque pouvons offrir
une proposition du prison mâcon qui
relaie une proposition italienne alors
il appelle sa communauté et non pas
confédération évident la question russe
se pose plus du tout comme air en 89 et
mais il ya le même raisonnement qu'il ya
des tas de pays qui sont une dizaine de
pays c'est pas que sur l'ukraine la
proposition de segi vin compris c'est le
royaume notamment c'est sur l'ensemble
des pays qui sont dans les limbes entre
les deux alors choix qui ont été membres
qui le sont plus oui on me dit choix et
il ya la vision et l'ukraine mais ceux
qui disent qu'on pourrait la faire
rentrer rapidement eux mentent en fait
aux ukrainiens peut-être pour à partir
de bons sentiments face c'est un
mensonge eu quand même manière qu'en
raison de tenir des tournois français de
dire ça va prendre des décennies de
lancer une proposition
ni de faire rentrer le crème en tout cas
des années bien sûr elles ne tiendront
plus aucune aucune des conditions il ya
tous les pays des balkans qui attendent
d l'albanie regarder le tout les
autistes ont cinq six ou sept là et puis
à des pays entre les deux pays et la
moldavie la géorgie donc il y avait pas
de concept est donc ces pays était dans
une sorte d' instabilité de fragilité
schumi à des manoeuvres variés donc je
trouve très intelligent d'avoir relooké
relance et reformulé cette idée qui va
être très débattue un très discuté c'est
très controversé mais c'est autour de
l'idée française relancé
franco-italienne en bavière elle que la
discussion va s'exercer donc je trouve
que c'est une c'est une bonne démarche
pour quelqu'un qui vient d'être réélu à
la présidence semestrielle pendant
encore deux mois ce
nom change au sol non pas dans le giron
parce que s'ils reviendront pas dans le
giron mais oui il faut qu'il y ait un
ensemble européen d'autant que la
situation actuelle la tête de poutine la
la la redécouverte de la des risques en
europe appellent quand même à ce qu'est
une sur deux
de vastes cadre au delà de l'union
proprement dit c'est à dire certains des
pays ont vocation à entrer un jour en
septembre par rené vautier pour l'entrée
mais d'autres pays vont dire ben on veut
négocier très bien c'est tout à fait
compatible dans la communauté politique
si elle secret si ça marche et puis en
même temps entamé des négociations donc
c'est très bien que ce débat nécessaire
s'organise dans la temps à venir au taux
de cette idée française
parmi les choses que le président la
république a évoqué à strasbourg hier il
ya également le l'idée de réviser les
traités en mettant fin à l'unanimité des
décisions il reprend sa une des
conclusions de la convention sur
l'avenir de l'europe est ce que est ce
que c'est une bonne idée il ya déjà très
état
est un membre qui contestent l'idée de
mettre fin à l'unanimité dans les
décisions est-ce qu'on rit on risque pas
d'assister à l'émergence d'une europe à
deux vitesses
non alors d'abord il y en a déjà mais
qu'ils aillent à l'euro ils n'ont pas
l'euro et schengen que celle d'il ya
plusieurs niveaux de participation dont
la question ses yeux est-ce qu'il
fallait agir dans le cadre des traités
existants agir mieux dire l'europe a
plutôt mieux agi ces derniers temps
depuis la commission von der leyen vous
changer les traités alors sel et le pour
et le contre parce que lancer la
discussion sur changer les traités c'est
une discussion d'être très compliquée
qui va durer des années
les puissants seront pas les mêmes il y
aura des crises et coup d'arrêt etc et
puis à supposer qu'on arrive à un
nouveau traité il faut le ratifier après
à l'unanimité donc sa place est allée
pendant des années bon donc certains
disaient y compris d'ailleurs dans
l'actuel gouvernement que il valait
mieux se contenter d'agir au mieux dans
les traités existants mais le président
d'après ce que je constate a conclu qu'
il vaut mieux pas ne pas entendre la
demande c'est pas la convention parce
que la convention séro zéro et 0 1% des
européens banquet 50000 paris ces
quelques longtemps fait bon voilà mais
il ya une demande forte du parlement qui
vaudrait une sorte de normalité la
semaine dernière oui ils veulent
augmenter les pouvoirs du parlement en
haut ils veulent nous sorte de régime
d'assemblée à l'échelle de l'europe on
n'est pas obligé de donner région
automatiquement mais mais ça correspond
assez dur nettoyer c'est dur c'est de ne
pas entendre non plus vous n'avez pas le
sentiment que ça correspond à une
attente forte des citoyens en europe
notamment en france nous revoir les
traités de régler un certain nombre
d'études l'attend telle qu'on la voit
elle ils veulent une europe qui
fonctionne bien qu'ils soient efficaces
par rapport au parlement qui les
intéressent donc il pourra aller plus
vite s'ils avaient pas l'unanimité sur
toutes les surfaces rassemblé test il
faudra démontrer le lien dans tout cas
là aussi c'est intéressant que l'idée
était lancée autour d'une proposition
française france ayant la présidence
semestrielle et que les débats à venir
qui vont être très compliqué très longue
s'organise on verra après alors ça veut
dire que puisque l'idée a été lancée
elle c'est là le rôle yeux du président
il faut qu'on s'organise on se sent
qu'on soit clair dans notre tête et nous
qu'est ce qu'on en attend quels sont les
domaines où on veut vraiment corriger
dans l'est dans quel cas les corrections
sur les meilleurs pour notre influence
qu'il faut le lead et souhaite une
france forte généraux de fortes à
l'arrivée vous allez vous aurez le temps
d'en reparler de 150 x et quelles
seraient les domaines justement la
france serait bénéfice de l'arrêté pour
vous
moi je prends le problème plutôt à
l'envié de dire je voudrais être sûr que
ça ne compte pas le nombre de cas où la
france peut être en minorité sur des
sujets essentiels pour nous en oublions
pas qu on a des positions à différentes
sinon c'est pas mignon mais original
souvent ça le politique tant cher sur la
défense sur le social sur la culture et
détente cet arbre donc il faut voir donc
vous êtes retrouvés à fait bon on risque
pas non risque pas parce que on
l'acceptera pas mais il se peut que dans
les débats qui vont se développer en
s'aperçoivent qu'on a intérêt nous à
l'élargissement de la majorité qualifiée
dans certains domaines le passage à la
majorité pardon plutôt que l'unanimité
dans d'autres non les jours deux pays
vont dire mes bras celle inverse oui bon
ça discussions mais l'europe c'est une
sorte de discussion permanente alors moi
je trouve ça très intéressant ce qui va
se passer une seule remarque il faut pas
que toute l'énergie des européens soit
engloutie par ça en fait donc il faut
continuer à agir le mieux possible dans
le cadre des traités existants ce qu'on
a vu d'ailleurs dans les dernières
années vous face à la pandémie ou le
retenait pas de compétences spéciales en
fait elle finalement les européens ont
plutôt bien réagi
la commission von der leyen fonctionne
plutôt bien le travail de breton et aix
et l'envié donc on peut faire beaucoup
de choses dans le cadre des traités si
on arrive à ajouter en plus de ça après
les controverses pour moi très longtemps
finalement un traité et qui permet de
mieux fonctionner tant mieux tant mieux
en tout cas il faut y aller c'est pas
une démarche magique un foyer avec des
idées très claires sur nos objectifs
maintenant
l'avouent sans doute là dessus comment
vous avez un doute sur la carte
c'est une remarque que global vu mon
expérience sur les négociations
on écrème marque un tournant dans
l'histoire de l'union
c'est peu dans l'histoire de l'union
dans l'histoire de l'europe en général
oui
non peut le mans s'est réveillée l'otan
servier l'otan pour le moment ça
réveiller l'esprit de défense dans les
pays européens mais dans le cadre de
l'alliance vers le discours très
important du champ diamant choles avec
lequel le plan macro ont été dits nayer
mais le sens le discours ya quelques
semaines la ville abandonnée en quelques
sols de pacifisme allemands
contemporains qui était venu le l'adn de
l'allemagne contemporaine il annoncé un
plan de de réarmement de 100 milliards
alors que l'allemagne a quasiment plus
d'armée en fait hormis l'annoncé sein en
annonçant l'achat de l'avion américain
donc pour me ment l'agression de poutine
a réveillé l'alliance atlantique y
compris pour des pinottes qu'ils veulent
maintenant est entrée
par exemple oui il n'y a pas de raison
on verra ça va être débattue mes yeux
leur demande est logique et je vois pas
comment l'alliance pourrait dire non par
rapport à ça compte tenu du contexte
ainsi il faut pas craindre la réaction
du reste oui bien sûr mais il reste à
transformer c'est ce à quoi va
s'employer le président dans les
dernières semaines de sa pré france
formé ce shoot show serait flags
européen en quelque chose d' européen
pour le mans c'est l'alliance donc ça
veut dire une affirmation des européens
dans l'alliance alors oui c'est le cadre
général de l'alliance que les européens
ont demandé après la guerre si aucune
demande et les américains avaient
accepté une affirmation européenne en
termes de moyens de capacités ceci cela
bon donc c'est une démarche importante
mais on peut pas dire que thématiquement
s'est réveillée l'union d'où la dose la
relance de la discussion sur le
changement du mode de fonctionnement
tout est lié
vous avez vous avez été ministre des
affaires étrangères de lionel jospin
sous jacques chirac à la fin les années
90 vous disiez tout à l'heure que
mitterrand et kohl voulait aider
gorbatchev après 89 est-ce que vous à
titre personnel vous avez imaginé
paprika points 9 rebonds avant gardisme
en arrivant des tarifs en 85 est-ce que
vous à titre personnel vous avez imaginé
un seul instant vous avez vous avez pu
imaginer un seul instant que 30 ans
après tout ça le la situation pouvait se
tendre à nouveau de manière aussi
exceptionnel avec la russie oui bien sûr
vous avez vu les choses venir qu'est-ce
qu'on a ratées enfin par la relation
avec eux on parle d'une longue période
oui mais oui après la fin de la vraie
date c'est pas la chute du mur c'est la
fin de lurs après la fin de leur choix
d'où la russie c'est là qu'ils n'ont pas
tout de suite mais pendant des années il
ya el cid est dû non le souvenir des
russes on leur dit la démocratie
désavoué la démocratie elle si
l'effondrement du niveau de vie à la
corruption pour les russes et ça c'est
des années eltsine à l'époque où il est
conseiller américain dans les ministères
russes la demande des russes imposer la
thérapie de choc 40% d'effondrement du
pouvoir d'achat 40% dans nos pays si les
gens pensent qu'ils ont perdu 0,5 ils
sont en révolution bon donc après il ya
eu le mandat poutine poutine depuis
medvedev et une longue période je pense
comme la plupart des américains vétérans
de la guerre froide que l'occident a
accumulé les erreurs et des provocations
et des maladresses ce n'est pas par
complaisance par rapport à la future rue
siro devenu nationaliste par disons
désinvolture ignorance on a gagné on a
gagné globalement et on s'en fiche un
peu de ce que pensent les russes les
chinois les arabes et les africains donc
ça c'est une période après après il ya
le début de l'évolution notamment à
partir de poutine 3 est une solution
vraiment nationaliste d'ailleurs annoncé
par poutine dans des discours et autant
l'occident à mon avis c'est délicat dans
le débat aujourd'hui parce que quand on
voit les horaires en ukraine et les
bombardements c'est presque gênant mais
est quand même il faut comprendre le
débat lui aux etats-unis beaucoup plus
que dans les débats chez nous 1 donc
après on n'a pas été assez inclusif au
début du même qui singer la regrettée ça
qu'on n'est pas construit un système de
sécurité qui est imbriqué la russie et
dans un second temps toutes les
dernières années on n'a pas été assez
dissuasif et pas été assez ferme il faut
bien distinguer ce qu'on parle de 30 ans
donc depuis poutine 3 il ya un danger
évident évident même avant la firme
crimée et après etc etc
stabilité alors évidemment pas dans ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en ukraine mais
il ya une responsabilité de la part des
occidentaux dans ce qu'est devenu
poutine ce qui l'a amenée
aujourd'hui dans un colloque historique
on pourrait le dire oui mais c'est
délicat à manier en tout cas et c'est
pas que la russie à l'assemblée générale
des nations-unies il ya eu un vote après
l'agression de poutine et les relations
est évidente mais pas contestable et
puis la guerre est atroce et c'est en
vrai tout ça 140 pays ont condamné très
bien une quarantaine de pays a refusé de
condamner
quarantaine de pays qu'ils représentent
démographiquement 60 % de l'humanité il
ya là dedans il ya évidemment la chine
mais aussi l'inde donc quand même par
rapport à l'idée que on est les maîtres
du monde et ne l'avant-garde morale du
monde ces dates ou de répondre nos
valeurs nos critères nodar médecin de sa
faut que les occidentaux réfléchissent
là dessus parce que ça cautionne pas que
la russie cette arrogance un peu
désinvolte c'est la même chose qui a
conduit à faire entrer la chine dans
l'organisme mondial du commerce alors
qu'elle ne respecter aucune règle parce
que les occidentaux se sont dits à
l'époque on va les faire rentrer ils
vont se développer et ça va les rendre
automatiquement démocratique dont
quelqu'un même une série de d'absurdité
quoi donc faut qu'on atterrisse en ce
monde là en gardant évidemment
viscéralement de valeur mais il faut
comprendre qu' on va être obligé de
réinventer la coexistence pacifique avec
les uns des autres mais pas avec les
rues si maintenant on peut pas se
l'urgence c'est d'arrêter la guerre et
la souffrance non voir un jour
pour vous un jour mais il faudra y aura
toujours la russie à côté avec la russie
mais katyn c'est encore possible j'en
sais rien est la limite ça dépendra de
ce que nous demanderons les ukrainiens
un moment donné s'ils veulent arrêter
les combats ou pas ou enregistrer les
faits criant été mais en tout cas il y
aura toujours une russie à côté qui sera
jamais une social démocratie scandinave
donc vont intégrer ça quand il faudra
arrêter là franchement missionnaires et
normalisatrice mais en même temps
défendre absolument en étant à le bouter
sur nos valeurs il sait pas pour tout de
suite ce rendez vous justement dit c'est
pas la
guerre on attendait on a
marqué la capitulation de l'allemand
nazis jour de la victoire en russie on
attendait une démonstration de force on
attendait même l'annoncé d'une entré en
guerre il n'en a rien été la prononcer
un discours ce sont provocation majeur
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il faut y voir
une volonté d escalade de la part de
vladimir poutine non c'est ce serait
trop trop beau le mauvais trop blâmer on
attendait ces douces mais poutine a
aucune raison de faire les discours
annoncé à l'as vence par l'occident il a
sa propre logique comme que nous
détestons que nous combattons mais c'est
sa propre logique alors il faut prendre
acte du fait que oui il n'y a pas de
surenchère n'y a pas de bonnes nouvelles
bon mais ne pas s'y fier on peut pas
naturellement donc faut rester très
vigilant très mobilisés mais peut-être
est-ce l'occasion de
le souligner faut pas embrayer sur
l'évolution récente du discours
américain
les patients quelques semaines deux on
va aider l'ukraine à résister très bien
on va aider l'ukraine à pas être envahi
dominer très bien il faut armer
l'ukraine faut les aider les réfugiés
l'argentin ce terrible très bien il ya
un discours américain qui dit sont en
profiter pour affaiblir la russie vont
en profiter pour dire que petit ne peut
pas rester aussi complètement différent
cherche à tirer
discours comment les dangereuses
discours je pense je pense que les
européens doivent pas être sur cette
ligne il faut garder l'unité des
occidentaux mais ce qu'ils vont pas
faire aboutir le cadeau ce dossier
divisé lorient d'éléments amérique très
important aux états unis qui joue pas en
europe c'est les élections aux états
unis début novembre 2001 et il faut pas
oublier faut pas que les aider les
auditeurs jet ou telle structure soit
choqué il ya les lobbys c'est quand même
très très très puissant il est âgé dit
on sait très bien bon et il ya une
douzaine de polonais ou d'ukrainiens ou
autres notamment à chicago qui joue un
rôle très important dans des dans des
états qui sont divisés entre
républicains et démocrates dont on voit
bien que l'ensemble du système démocrate
s'est emparé du sujet doué visite à kiev
tout le temps qu'ils encouragent
d'ailleurs peut-être les ukrainiens aux
dépens de l'ukrainien à vouloir
reconquérir fait il ya quand même un
risque donc moi je suis plus qu'on me
demande mon avis je suis plus à l'aise
avec la ligne française et allemande par
rapport à 110 ans lui par tous les
moyens l'ukraine harissa les guerres
sans entrer dans la guerre nous mêmes et
on va pas au delà on se lance pas dans
une opération anti russe et alors qu'à
washington vous avez des excités je
parle pas de byron qui dit il faut faire
de l'ukraine pour poutine sorte
d'équivalent de l'afghanistan mais assez
peu patch aline des européens on est en
première ligne il ya un peuple ukrainien
mais on poursuit les livraisons d'armes
jean yves le drian il dit on n'est pas
kobe des gérants tant qu'on n'en voit
pas de dom au sol c'est ça aussi pour
vous la ligne de la belligérance jetons
s'engage sur le oui l on peut y lire
que le drian est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
il a une obsession ukrainienne
moi j'ai jamais cru qu'il avait un plan
général pour refaire le lampy rodez
choses comme ça et encore moins lurs
l'obsession du training qui est partagé
par beaucoup de gens russie seul
génétine penser comme lui sur l'histoire
l'histoire le rôle de l'ukraine et
cetera mais cette obsession ukrainienne
aurait pu ne pas tout envahir et là je
renvoie donc au débat sur les années du
début mai dix ou quinze premières années
ben ça tout travail et la violence avec
l'église orthodoxe ultranationalistes et
là il a réveillé ou utiliser ou capter
comme on veut un nationalisme russe
violent donc je pense que le but était
spécifiquement ukrainien je pense pas
qu'il ait d'autre but si ce n'est les
opportunités comme il est fait en
géorgie et quelques années quand il ya
des minorités dans les pays voisins
autrefois contrôlé par murs qui sont
soit proche des ruches soit russophone
pas forcément riches au film enfin riche
faune ou qui sont en opposition avec le
pays où ils sont comme c'était le cas
des neuf cases en géorgie par exemple
donc il saisit les opportunités je pense
pas qu'ils aient
forcément d'autres pays non là je crois
que il est concentré sur les questions
de l'ukraine l'obsession de russie fier
du kremlin avec le discours délirant sur
les nazis et ses accus médecins disent
qu'elle est essentielle qui commence
c'est un discours délirant pour nous
équiper recolle en russie comment est ce
que vous expliquez que finalement le
l'essentiel de la population russe est
derrière poutine sur ces questions
malgré l'aspect délirant du discours il
ya plein de gens dans le monde qui
pensent pas comme vous savez il n'ya pas
un rôle aussi propagande en fait les les
médias les médias russes sur les
télévisions et où le discours dominant
qui est diffusée participent martin
danser en russie aujourd'hui c'est
spécialement verrouillé organisé exagéré
excessif mais les discours de propagande
dominant il y en a partout y compris
dans les pays libres mais les endroits
il est contredit secours et d'autres y
en a pas ah oui exactement votre
discours par exemple vous imaginez un
discours dominant sur le rôle
exceptionnel de l'amérique et s'éteint
mais il ya toujours eu des voix un petit
jeune en elle un petit peu et en russie
un peu à l'époque de la guerre en irak
presque pas bon en ce moment il ya des
voix dissonantes aux états unis qui
commence à dire nos des think tanks
attention on va trop loin on est trop
provocateur mais c'est rien assez
importants du discours global aux états
unis mais ça existe et la liberté de le
dire puis un moment ou un autre ils
reviennent sur le débat on ici non c'est
complètement verrouillé donc on en est
ramenée à des spéculations sur ce que
pensent les russes et la plupart des des
entreprises sur ce filon talent qui
avaient énormément en russie au début à
la demande de poutine d1 mais direction
des éditions des employés là bas qui ont
des relations qui ont des correspondants
du 10 mai de tous ces gens sont
épouvantés par le choix du président
poutine y comprennent pas de ces gens là
vivaient dans l'idée que la russie
allait s'intégrer dans un ensemble au
mondial de plus en plus combien sont-ils
moi je n'en sais rien et personne ne le
sait vraiment il ya il doit y en a 120
millions de russes quelque chose comme
ça damien bonne dizaine de millions de
russes engagés dans le dans le commerce
import-export l'énergie le cinéma la
culture ceci cela mais on ne peut pas
s'exprimer mais ça ça mais ça va pire
collé moi j'avais dit dès le début tout
de suite je lis c'est une erreur
tragique et pouvons pas pour les
ukrainiens c'est une erreur tragique
pour la russie ce choix de la part de
poutine et après
bon c'est pas parce qu'on a contribué à
réveiller le monstre qu'il faut pas le
combattrons apple soit là mais un jour
ou l'autre je pense que rennes réussit
différentes mais qui sera jamais tout à
fait une russie
tel que les européens l'ont souhaité un
piper secondaire qui alignait sur nos
l'honore mais qui fait ce qu'on lui
demande ça sera jamais ça ça dure un
pays compliqué cette biopile des siècles
si on entend les russes et une audi
depuis des siècles non et c'est surtout
été envahie par vous plutôt que
l'inversé débat très compliqué donc on
retrouvera la question de comment on
fait pour voisine et pour que existé
mais vous disais un jour je dis un jour
un jour après après pour le moment il
faut à tout prix cadets l'ukraine à
tenir bon tenir bon sans être nous mêmes
dans l'engrenage que nos jeux pinon ne
suivrait pas est-ce que les démocraties
ce sont des démocraties au monde est
fier très bien mais je voudrais pas
qu'on engage
le degré maximum a pas que la france et
concerne tous les pays
fournel le maximum de fermeté qui soit
tenable
de jour où il faut les débats devant les
parlements oui au tce est tenable si
réussies en matière de sanctions on a
sans doute été trop loin est-ce que les
effets contre-productifs en matière
d'énergie donc d'inflation il ya une
crise énorme qui se prépare
troll en matière de sanctions
économiques il fallait il fallait pour
construire pense qu'il faudra les
estimés par exemple il faudra préciser
il faudrait organiser les choses pour
que le blé le blé d'ukraine et même de
russie puisse sortir puis s'est
transporté echirey financer cinq
anciennes beaucoup de pays de la rive
sud dans lesquelles personne n'a intérêt
ce qui est des modes de la fin des
renversements de gouvernement donc les
sanctions vont pas lui prendre que ma
c'est pas la bible qu'il faut travailler
dessus
l'autre actualité qui vous concerne je
disais vous présidez l'institut françois
mitterrand il ya un colloque aujourd'hui
qui se tient au sénat sur le legs
économique des premières années du
premier quinquennal de françois
mitterrand quand vous regardez le parti
socialiste aujourd'hui est ce qu'on vous
dit c'est la fin du parti socialiste
françois mitterrand oui oui c'est la fin
du pacte solide de franche amitié alors
il ya forcément une chute chez lui une
forme ou sous une autre parce que les
ledit gir 2 d'égalité de justice cet
intérêt sera toujours présent mais je ne
sais pas pas qu'elle le chemin il
s'exprimera mais là c'est une mi-temps
est un organe historique d'un organe
autour de l' on entretient la mémoire de
la personne de françois mitterrand de
son action de sa présidence aux yeux un
ensemble de deux polémiques babette sur
pas mal de sujets donc il ya un travail
à faire et on a aujourd'hui donc un
grand club français que je suis là tôt
le matin chez vous
les années décisives et là on reprend le
lay économie de 80 86 parce qu'en fait
beaucoup de gens en gardant mais même
les gens de gauche il en gardait en
mémoire ce santé 11,72 programme commun
quatre ans de l'élection et 83 le
tournant européen on va dire en résumé
et les liens sommes intervenants de très
haut niveau se serait conclue par
laurent fabius qui vont dire nous faut
revenir sur la pensée économique qui
selon nous est une brosse et
modernisatrice donc de l'ensemble de la
période 81 86 après il ya la première
des trois cohabitations c'est autre
chose voilà on est dans notre rôle en
faisant ce travail encore une fois
historique et pas polémique et pas
politique
la politique au sens partisan
politiciens et vous un titre personnel
s'il s'agissait de relancer quelque
chose ou de reconstruire un nouveau
parti quel serait votre ligne a
maintenant que je riais m'exprimer là
dessus j'ai aucune autorité sur ce plan
je n'ai pas deux j'ai pas tomber édition
derrière moi j'ai pas avait une histoire
personnelle regard
garcia liste aujourd'hui comment vous le
regardez
de la part de la direction du parti
socialiste de se ranger derrière
derrière les enfants j'ai pas commenter
les éléments tout à fait récent choc
c'est une toute autre histoire parce
qu'évidemment le faudrait distinguer le
programme de mélenchon qui est le
contraire exact de ce pourquoi on
travaillait et militer gouverner la
gauche de gouvernement les sociaux
démocrates c'est le contraire exact sur
à peu près chaque fois sauf la
planification écologique qui est une
bonne idée le font d'ailleurs un peu les
entreprises déjà plus que les états mais
tout le reste c'est tout à fait
indifférent c'est incompatible donc je
vois sa tristement mais ce qui
m'intéressait
c'est triste parce que c'est son
débouché possible sans débouchés
possibles c'est à dire pour vous le il
n'y a pas la victoire à la clé
l'initiative non chance femme je
franchis dans la plainte toute façon le
non non je pense pas est ce que c'est la
lame en revanche elle
mais je sais pas j'ai pas de légitimité
à trancher sur ces points toubon de son
point de vue dans la rue il ya plein de
gens qui ont des points de vue là-dessus
je crois que les les gens qui ont
participé à la grande gauche du
gouvernement voyez en beat torrent et
rocard jospin et c'est bon ils doivent
se demander ce qu'ils font car il ya
ceux qui se disent finalement
macro incarne ça aujourd'hui et chaque
fois les schémas con pour constituer une
belle le centre gauche on va dire ça
quelques-uns le l'ont fait d'ailleurs
dont ils vont dire ma mélenchon n'a pas
le choix faut distinguer le programme
est totalement révulsif et l'accord
électoral qui est un accord de survie
qui peut se comprendre mais il reste
donc de gens qui vont certainement dans
les semaines qui viennent c'est à dire
faut quand même qu'on recrée un espace
de réflexion pour cette gauche de
gouvernement à réinventer ça existe
ailleurs en europe donc pourquoi pas en
france mais ça supposerait qu'il prenne
de front des problèmes très difficiles
par exemple en ce qui me concerne ce que
le donnerai mon avis je pense que
l'incapacité
de la gauche de gouvernement apporter
une réponse raisonnable de gauche à la
demande normale de sécurité des gens la
demande normale d'identité haut de gamme
qu'on préserve à peu près leur identité
la demande normale de maîtrise des flux
migratoires la demande normal que le
droit d'asile ne soit pas massivement
détournés ont été emmenés cas pas eu de
réponse de gauche parce que la gauche
était gêné en disant c'est du racisme et
du fascisme et s'est du coup le peuple
ait complètement disparu on voit bien
les scores électoraux et le peuple on le
retrouve chez marine le pen qui a
récupéré beaucoup d'anciens électeurs
communistes par exemple un petit peu
chez les et bourré beaucoup chez
mélenchon donc si la gauche se
reconstitue après ceux qui seront pas
chez makro ni chez mélenchon et de
aborder ces questions ces questions et
clarifier enfin la question européenne
dise on y sont comme elles risquent pas
d'être pour l'europe pour l'europe il
faut dire voilà ce qu'ils ont accès
voilà ce qu'on comptait souhait ce qu'on
veut changer ça donc un énorme travail
mais je pense qu'à vingt à trente
personnalités de cette famille politique
là qui vont s'y atteler maintenant dont
françois hollande et bernard cazin je
n'entre pas dans leur merci beaucoup et
hubert védrine merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin je rappelle le colloque
qui se déroulera aujourd'hui au sénat
sur le legs économique des années me
sert entre 81 et 86 merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité perméthrine à
une mauvaise français la sécheresse
chaleur donc depuis la crainte d'un
étaient à sec c'est à la une de votre
journal
[Musique]